bonjour pour ce deuxième épisode de
gentes dames hadas je vais vous
présenter christine de pisan une femme
de lettres qui a vécu entre le 14e et le
xvème siècle elle n'est en 1365 à venise
mais déménage à partir de l'âge de 4 ans
en france parce que son père thomas de
pisan est nommé astrologue du roi
charles 5
j'aime les astrologues à 15 ans elle
épouse etienne de castel qui est notaire
et secrétaire du roi charles vi celui
qui vient après charles 5
donc ils sont heureux ensemble ils ont
trois enfants dont un fils timmer en bas
âge et elle connaît sûrement d'autres
grossesse parce qu'elle déclare être
souvent enceinte
mais ce bonheur ne dure que quelques
années en 1387 son père meurt puisse son
mari en outre à 190 et donc à l'âge de
25 ans elle se retrouve seule et devant
gérer la famille des compris sa mère et
une nièce est donc obligé de travailler
elle commence par vendre des terres qui
avait appartenu à son père mais ça ne
suffit pas d'autant que certaines
personnes lui font des procès pour des
questions de grandes foncières
elle doit bien gagner sa vie elle se
lance donc dans l'écriture à partir de
1399 d'abord en rédigeant des poèmes des
balades puis des livres en prose lorsque
sa notoriété commence à croître ses
premiers livres soit en partie
autobiographique puisque lé parle de la
perte de son mari et de ses difficultés
à faire vivre la famille ensuite elle
change de ton et produit des écrits un
peu plus engagée sur la société
française de son époque elle s'instruit
seule puisqu'elle n'a pas eu accès à
l'école et dans plusieurs de ses livres
elle tente de dresser le portrait d'un
couple royal idéal selon elle le bon roi
doit être noble de coeur respecter les
codes de la chevalerie et avoir acquis
la sagesse par l'étude et les conseils
de ses proches tandis que la bonne reine
doit d'être vertueuse et est chargé de
faire respecter la paix et l'amour de la
société ces livres sont lus par les
personnages les plus importants du
royaume puisque philippe le hardi lui
commandent le livre de fait et de bonnes
moeurs du roi charles ii 5 en 1405
philippe le hardi duc de bourgogne elle
dédiée aussi des livres à louis 11 et
rédige également année
deux faits d'armes et de chevalerie
destiné à la noblesse française et qui
explique les bonnes manières de faire la
guerre un traité de guerre écrit par une
femme au 15ème siècle je trouve ça pas
mal
elle y parle de la manière dont les rois
doivent mener une bataille de grands
événements marquants au niveau militaire
et aussi de droit dame
sa carrière prend fin après le livre de
paix de 1412 en 1418 paris est envahi
par les bourguignons elle se réfugie
alors au prieuré de saint louis de
poissy où elle finit ses jours et à
l'humeur en 1430 christine de pisan est
donc la première femme de lettres à
vivre de sa plume et ça n'a pas toujours
été une situation facile dès le début du
xvème siècle malgré sa notoriété elle
subit les critiques de plusieurs autres
auteurs surtout par rapport au fait
qu'elle est une femme
cette exception lui garantit une forte
notoriété pendant un siècle puisqu'elle
est réédité jusque mai 489 mais ensuite
elle tombe dans l'oubli
elle est de nouveau étudié au 19e siècle
où on considère alors que dans ses
écrits elle critiquait la monarchie ce
qui n'est pas vraiment le cas puisque
elle dressait le portrait d'un couple et
le royal idéal mais a critiqué surtout
le règne de charles ciss celui qu'elle a
connu elle considère quand même que la
monarchie est le meilleur type de régime
qui soit et considère aussi que le
peuple et de toute façon ignorants et
facilement manipulable à très charnue
donc au début du 20e siècle
elle est considérée comme une compil
attriste elle lisait des livres et
s'approprier les connaissances de ses
livres dans ses écrits un peu comme moi
dans cette vidéo puisque j'ai largement
bénéficié du mémoire d'un pote pour
écrire cet épisode et je l'en remercie
christine de pisan devient aussi un
emblème du féminisme dans la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
alors même si elle est effectivement la
première femme de lettres à vivre de ce
qu'elle écrivait mieux vaut éviter les
anachronismes
dans ses écrits et christine de pisan
réaffirme la place des femmes dans la
société mais ne cherche pas à changer
l'ordre établi
ça c'est françoise eaux tranquilles être
si vous voulez aller plus loin il
n'empêche qu'elle était une autre ismo
dern pour son époque puisque l aborder
des sujets tels que la guerre la
politique etc
et rien que pour ça je pense qu'elle
mérite sa place parmi les gentes dames
badass merci d'avoir regarder cet
épisode et on se retrouve dans deux
semaines pour une femme qui avait
largement sa place dans la gueule
politique du 16ème siècle première tour
[Musique]